okay this is really great i have another
one of these moments of clarity on fox
news
over which the fox news audience attacks
its own hosts now i want to remind you
these segments are for entertainment
purposes only
uh just because there's a moment of
clarity on fox doesn't mean fox news is
now a trustworthy
news source we're analyzing this sort of
as a curiosity that is interesting
because
of the widely ranging circumstances on
fox since the election
on the one hand you have chris wallace
occasionally making
sense on the other hand the nighttime
opinion hosts
are insisting trump actually won because
joe biden stole the election
and meanwhile trumpists are marching on
washington dc
and in arizona chanting fox news sucks
so this is
for the curiosity of it i'm not trying
to inculcate the idea
that maybe we can trust fox news we
can't but let's look at this one clip
here is reporter and host john roberts
interviewing chris wallace john roberts
brings up this bizarre
claim that even though trump is losing
the vote count
he's in some sense winning and chris
wallace is just having none of it
may take some questions this afternoon
obviously i imagine the first questions
would be about where he is in terms of
if he is going to continue to fight this
battle to try to unearth
new votes that could turn around the
current vote count or if he will concede
the president does seem though in a way
chris to be
winning even as he is losing in the
current vote count because
for his die-hard fans he is trying to
make the case that
he didn't really lose the election that
it was taken from him is that an
argument that he can credibly make
well not in terms of the numbers at
least so far unless we see
something from these lawsuits that we
haven't seen so far
which is uh serious fraud and fraud of a
dimension that it would actually
overturn the results
he's not losing these states for
instance pennsylvania by 500 votes
like florida in 2000 he's losing it by
40 or 50 000 votes
so unless we see fraud of that dimension
i don't know that he can credibly say
that the election has been taken from
him but
that doesn't mean he won't continue to
make the argument and as we know
uh donald trump got more votes than any
person in history running for president
this year
except for joe biden this year so uh you
know there are tens of millions of
people
who who love this president who are in
the uh
trump base uh and and i suspect they
will be susceptible to the argument
that somehow that this election was
taken from him
i like the use of the term susceptible
by chris wallace what he's really
talking about is
bamboozlable right suggesting
that there are people in trump's base
who even though this is a bad argument
will fall for will be susceptible to
donald trump's uh argument that in some
way
he really did win and that is true chris
wallace is right
the trumpist is susceptible to it as the
polls show
86 percent of trump voters as of
a few days ago believe that joe biden
did not legitimately win the election
they are susceptible to it about
60 percent of trump voters believe not
only did biden not legitimately win
but biden's not even going to be sworn
in if you look at that the the polling
data we looked at i believe it was last
thursday or friday
friday 60 of trump voters believe that
what donald trump is doing legal
challenges and
you know whatever else tweeting that
it's eventually going to overturn the
results of the election so chris wallace
is right
but chris wallace was getting killed for
these comments and what's stunning
is that many trumpets don't even really
understand the numbers and that's
because
trump campaign people don't want to give
them the numbers we talked about this a
little bit earlier in the show
during the segment in which fox host
leland vittert
and trump communications staffer um
aaron aaron perrini perrone parini
we're arguing in a state like
pennsylvania for example where joe biden
won by 72
trump campaign people won't actually say
our legal challenge that we put in
writing is about 44 000 votes they'll
never say that
because whatever is the case with 44 000
votes
even if we said every one of those votes
is actually a trump vote um biden's
winning
by 72 thousand votes you often hear
rudy giuliani and others say 700 000
votes appeared or disappeared or
whatever
they're talking about the fact that
early on election night
trump was up by several hundred thousand
in pennsylvania
and ultimately as expected we talked
about the red mirage
scenario eventually um the numbers
reversed
and as mail-in ballots were counted
and those disproportionately went for
joe biden the lead shrank and shrank and
shrank
and eventually it stopped being a lead
for donald trump it became a deficit for
donald trump so
when trump is here these campaign people
talking about
hundreds of thousands of votes they
think
wow that's enough to flip the election
the reality is that in court and we'll
see if
reportedly rudy giuliani today is going
to actually start representing trump in
court which sounds hilarious
maybe he'll present something different
but so far in court
they are talking about small batches of
votes where
even if the complaints went somewhere
and even if
every so-called contested ballot became
a trump ballot
it still would not overturn the results
in any state never mind in enough states
to flip this election from joe biden to
donald trump
they won't tell you that let's now
continue our discussion and this is
something i've been looking forward to
to talking about for a few days now
let's talk about how fox news
has out has radicalized itself
into a problem with trumpists okay
that's that's my next story
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because all of their shirts come
with a patented
zipper hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most importantly
just overall it makes the shirt fit much
better and look better the carefully
designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed collar
that won't fall down and lay flat which
i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout